c'est un tout premier
téléphone portable
[Musique]
et le premier appel téléphonique a été passé dans les
rues de New York sur la 6e Avenue à New
York près de l'hôtel Hilton
et je n'ai vraiment pas pensé à qui
j'allais appeler jusqu'au  à la dernière minute,
puis il m'est venu à l'esprit que je devrais
appeler mon homologue du Bell
System, j'ai dit Joel, c'est Marty Cooper,
il a dit bonjour Marty
Joel, je vous parle sur un téléphone portable,
mais un vrai téléphone portable
personnel.
ordinateur de poche
il y avait des colonies à l'autre bout
de la ligne je pense que c'était génial contre
Chase
you
that mineral business
ES
il y a un potentiel je sais que cela
ressemble à une exagération mais je
la regarde aller dans une génération ou deux nous
allons vaincre la maladie  éliminer la
maladie
les gens avec des smartphones
les regardent trop ils sont
pris dans le smartphone et je dois
vous dire que je suis dévasté quand je vois quelqu'un
traverser la rue et regarder son
téléphone portable et c'est très courant
qu'il soit hors de son  esprits
[Musique]
tout d'abord
et comme vous le savez